what does the bible say about
death
can the dead communicate with the living
is it possible for once a person has
died
to come back to their house again and
speak to their loved ones
and what will the ultimate result of the
devil's deception of spiritualism be
in the light of the last days of verse
history
one of satan's greatest deceptions
is spiritualism
down through the centuries he has used
spiritualistic manifestations to deceive
millions of people
who are the spirits
of spiritualism
can the dead communicate with the living
sir arthur conan doyle
englishman
spiritualist said this he said there is
no question
that the dead still live because i talk
with them there is no death in the
graveyard was doyle right when he made
that statement
if you have an apparition
and a dead loved one appears to you
is that of god
to encourage you
it is of the is it of the devil to
deceive you
or is it simply
a figment of the imagination
the devil used spiritualism in the
garden of eden to deceive eve you
remember that he spoke through a serpent
to deceive her
modern spiritualism began in 1848 in the
united states
three sisters living in hydesville new
york with their parents they were called
the fox sisters
heard when they went to bed at night
some strange wrappings
there was a rumor that the house that
they had purchased was haunted
and as they heard these strange
wrappings knock knock knock knock
they developed a system of communication
with these wrappings
and
they termed the being on the other end
that was communicating with them old mr
split foot it was simply another name of
course for
satan
and they continued to communicate with
this old mr split foot
the three sisters eventually became
spiritualists
and based on that foundation of
spiritualism spiritualism has grown by
the thousands there are tens of
thousands of spirituals really hundreds
of thousands
throughout the united states
and the world
but what does the bible say about
spiritualism
what does the bible say about
death
can the dead communicate with the living
is it possible for once a person has
died
to come back to their house again and
speak to their loved ones
and what will the ultimate result of the
devil's deception of spiritualism be
in the light of the last days of verse
history let's jump right into our topic
based on the bible i love that old poem
what says the bible the blessed bible to
me the teachings of men so often
mislead me but what says the bible the
blessed bible to me first thing that we
want to set out very clearly is that
once a person dies that it is impossible
for that individual to communicate with
the living
ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse 5. for the
living know that they will die what are
the living know what does every living
human being know it knows they will die
but the dead know nothing how much did
the dead know the bible says the dead
know nothing not one thing as would say
in spanish nada they know nothing
for they have no more reward the memory
of them is forgotten their love their
hatred their envy these emotions have
now perished
verse 10
whatever your hand finds to do do it
with all your might for there is no work
or device or knowledge or wisdom in the
grave where you're going
so the bible says the dead know nothing
the bible presents death as a sleep in
53 different places
it calls death but a rest you remember
when jesus friend lazarus died jesus
said i go to wake him up out of sleep
his disciples said if he's sleeping he's
going to do well
and jesus then the bible says in john
chapter 11 verse 11 to 14 jesus spoke of
his death so in the bible
the dead know nothing they don't know
anything and death is but asleep
is it possible then in the light of that
for a dead person to return to their
house and talk to their living relatives
well the book of job answers that
question very powerfully very clearly
for us job chapter 7.
when we look at what scripture says we
are preserved from the deceptions of our
day job chapter 7
verse 7 and on oh remember that my life
is a breath
mine eye will never see
never again see good
wow might i will never again see good
once i die i'm not going to come back to
the world to see good or evil the eye of
him who sees me will see me no more
well job says once i die the eye of him
who sees me is going to do what see me
no more
as the cloud verse 9 as the cloud
disappears and vanishes away so he who
goes down to the grave
does
not come up he shall never return to his
house nor shall his place know him
anymore
could the bible make it any plainer he
who goes down to the grave what does it
say does not come up
and then scripture says that he will not
return to his house
well does that mean that the grave is
the ultimate end does that mean when you
die you go into the grave it's a dark
hole in the ground a long night without
a morning is that what that means
what does it mean when it says he come
up no more
when would he come up if he came up
job answers that question in job chapter
and we're just developing a brief
outline of death
and so we can understand spiritualism
job the 14th chapter verse 12 so man
lies down and does not rise so he
doesn't rise until when next phrase till
the heavens are no more they will not
awake nor be roused from their sleep
oh that you would hide me in the grave
that you would conceal me until your
wrath is past
that you would appoint me a set time
remember me if a man dies shall he live
again now notice that's the question
isn't if a man dies shall we live again
all the days of my hard service i will
wait till my change comes you shall call
and i will answer you you shall desire
the work of your hands
so
when a person dies
they cannot return to their house they
don't come out of their grave until job
says the day of the appointed time of
the glorious resurrection of christ
so according to scripture death is a
sleep
until the return of jesus and you
remember in first corinthians chapter 15
verse 51 to 54 the bible says
the apostle paul writing talks about
the day that christ will come
talks about the day that the dead will
be resurrected acts romans corinthians
new testament first corinthians chapter
15 listen to the word of the lord
starting with verse 51 behold i tell you
a mystery he's saying i tell you a
mystery but it's a mystery that's solved
in the bible
we shall not all sleep remember death is
but a what sleep until when till jesus
comes we don't rise we don't go back to
our house until jesus comes behold i
tell you a mystery we shall not all
sleep but we shall be changed when in a
moment in the twinkling of an eye at the
last trumpet for the trumpet will sound
the dead will be raised incorruptible
and we shall be changed
for this corruptable must put on
incorruption this mortal must put on
immortality
so according to scripture
when we die we rest we cannot return to
our house
the dead do not appear to the living
and we rest if we are righteous and
believers until the day that jesus comes
and the dead are resurrected
first thessalonians chapter 4 verse 16
and 17 says the lord himself shall
descend from heaven with a what
shout
with the trumpet of god the voice of the
archangel and the trump of god and the
dead in christ will rise first
then we which are alive and remain shall
be caught up together with them to meet
the lord in the air
so we rest until the glorious day of the
second coming of christ when the dead
are resurrected and the living righteous
are changed and together
with their immortal bodies with the dead
that have been resurrected that are
righteous and the living that are
righteous are caught up to me christ in
the sky
understanding this saves you from a
thousand errors
and deceptions
one night i was preaching in the
philippines
and a typhoon came it was dark and the
wind was blowing water was flowing
through the streets and
rain was pelting down
we were to have a meeting that night and
i went to the auditorium made our way
there but a few people were in this
darkened auditorium i had to dismiss
them and go home i was preaching in fact
on the thousand years the millennium a
thousand years of darkness
and i said we can't have the meeting
tonight and they said pastor we have to
have it because
you announced the topic a thousand years
of darkness and we think
it began tonight i insured them that it
didn't but i spoke shortly sent them
home
the next night or two after the meeting
one of the participants in the meeting
came to me he had been
in the philippine army
i was a ranking officer in fact in the
philippine army
and he came to me and he said pastor
mark let me tell you this story you
remember the other night when the
typhoon came yeah i sure do
he said i was sleeping wind was blowing
rattling the windows in my house
rattling the house
and he said i woke up
now his wife had died some years before
and he said i woke up and i looked up
and i saw
the form of my wife young no wrinkles
beautiful and she reached out her arms
and she was coming toward me
and as i saw her she called me she
beckoned and
come hug me he said i looked up
and i remembered pastor mark what you
said i remembered what the bible said
the living know that they shall die but
the dead not anything
the dead cannot return to their house
job 7
we shall wait and sleep until the
resurrection job 14 and he said when i
saw
that form of my wife he said i cried out
jesus jesus
this
is not my wife
this is a demon this is a evil spirit
masquerading as my wife in the name of
christ be gone
and he said pastor mark
the form of my wife
turned to a hideous demon and
disappeared
knowing what the bible says
protects us
from the wiles of satan and the
deceptions of satan in the last days of
earth's history
satan is going to use spiritualism in an
attempt to unite church and state
he will use false miracles he will use
signs he'll use wonders the spirits of
demons will go out to the
political leaders of the world to try to
bring them together
look at a few texts that are very clear
on this
revelation the 16th chapter and the 14th
verse
revelation 16 verse 14.
here the bible is talking about earth's
final war the battle of armageddon and
it says in revelation 16 verse 14
then i saw three unclean spirits come
out of the mouth the beast
the mouths of the the dragon the beast
and the false prophet
they are spirits of demons
performing signs or miracles which go
out to the kings of the whole world
to gather them
to the battle
of the great day
of god almighty so here you have a clear
bible passage than in the last days
satan's going to use spiritualism that's
why it's so important to know the truth
of the bible and he is going to deceive
multitudes through spiritualism he's
going to get the kings of the earth the
political leaders of the earth to form a
religious political alliance and the
people of god who do not go along will
be persecuted
now revelation 18 describes this union
look revelation chapter 18 verse 2 3 and
he cried mightily with a loud voice
babylon the great is fallen is fallen
babylon is a symbol of false religion
falsehood
it has become a habitation of demons who
lives in babylon
demons spiritualism a prison of every
foul spirit a cage of every unclean
hated bird
for all nations have drunk the wine of
the wrath of her fornication what's
fornication it's an illicit union
so what happens
the religions of this world
except god's faithful true people will
ultimately unite with the political
powers of the world and the merchants of
the world
and they'll have this triple triumphant
of error political leaders financial
leaders religious leaders
and they will again
be dominated by spiritualism look
for all nations have drunk the wine of
the wrath of her fornication fornication
is an illicit union
the kings of the earth have committed
fornication with her with whom
with babylon this false religious
movement and the merchants of the earth
who's that the financial leaders
have become rich through the abundant of
her delicacies and i heard another voice
from heaven saying come out of her my
people as you partake a verse
sins
unless you receive her plagues
what kind of a picture do we see there
the picture that we see there
is that the devil uses spiritualism
dead loved ones appear
beings like angels appear
false miracles take place
signs and wonders take place
and this is all to deceive as many
people as possible
to get them ready to take the mark of
the beast
so that they will be
in opposition to god's people and
eventually in rebellion and disobedience
to god be ultimately lost ellen white
a writer whom i deeply respect who i
believe personally
has received
divine inspiration from god
writes about this time in a book called
great controversy page 588 and 589
she says
through the true great through the two
great errors the immortality of the soul
what's that the immortality of the soul
that's the idea the soul leaves the body
of death
in sunday sacredness satan will bring
the people under his deceptions
while the former lays the foundation of
spiritualism
the latter creates a bond of sympathy
with rome
now next paragraph as spiritualism more
closely imitates the nominal
christianity of the day
it has greater power to deceive and
ensnare
satan himself is converted after the
modern order of things he will appear in
the character of an angel of light
through the agency of spiritualism
miracles will be wrought the sick will
be healed many undeniable wonders will
be performed
and as the spirits will perform
profess faith in the bible
and manifest respect for the
institutions of the church
their work will be accepted as a
manifestation of divine power
so here's the picture
at a time of unusual crisis in the world
earthquake famine fire flood
war conflict strife
economic disaster where our money is
worth very little at a time of that
total chaos in the world
the devil will begin to work
he'll work
through spiritualism there'll be false
miracles there'll be false signs false
wonders
so called dead will appear it could even
be that some will masquerade james and
john
and some will masquerade things like
daniel and jeremiah they will
lead a people away from the bible truth
they will lead people to unite
with this political religious financial
power block
they will say the world must come
together in unity
but it's not a unity based on truth
remember what jesus said in john 17 17
sanctify them through thy word
thy word is truth
now you might be wondering how can i
keep from this overwhelming delusion
how can i keep from being deceived
by the spiritualism of the last days
well number one understanding death will
help a great deal
but there's something else
that's extremely important
isaiah chapter 8
describes how we can keep from being
deceived
in the last days of verse history
isaiah chapter 8
we're looking at verse 19.
when they say to you
seek those who are mediums and wizards
who whisper and mutter
shanata people seek their god should not
they seek the dead on behalf of the
living so what is it saying it's saying
they're gonna there's gonna be this
great spiritualistic movement but then
it says to the law to the testimony if
they speak not according to this word
there's no light in them
no light if they don't speak according
to god's law and part of the ten
commandment law the fourth commandment
is what remember the sabbath day to keep
it holy six days shalt thou labor into
all thy work but the seventh day is the
sabbath the lord thy god
written
on tables of stone with god's own finger
god says
if you want to keep from being deceived
in the last days of earth's history
number one know what the bible says
about death the death is about a rest
that the dead can't return to their
house that the devil can masquerade as
dead loved ones second corinthians 11 14
he is
masquerading at times as an angel of
light so he tries to deceive through
spiritualism so understand that death is
but a rest of the coming of jesus
secondly the bible says
don't go after some movement that leads
you away from the law of god
when the fallen church
when the state powers when the financial
powers unite and enforce a decree to
keep us from obeying the law of god the
bible says to the law unto the testimony
if they speak not according to this word
there's no light in them it doesn't say
there's no power because the devil can
work with power it doesn't say there's
no love because the devil can use an
emotional form of counterfeit love it
says there's no light and what's light
light
is what
we follow how can you keep from being
deceived by loving the truth notice what
the bible says
in the book of thessalonians
here
scripture is speaking in thessalonians
about the antichrist
and when the antichrist appears and how
he will attempt to deceive the
multitudes and it tells us how we can
keep from being deceived look
second thessalonians chapter 2
verse 7 and onward the mystery of
lawlessness see the mystery of
lawlessness paul says
the mystery of lawlessness is already at
work so already in paul's day
you have lawlessness taking place a
departure from the law of god a
disobeying of the commandments of god
grace
never leads us to disobedience it always
leads us to obedience
the scripture says the mystery of
lawlessness is already at work only he
who now restrains will do so until he's
taken out of the way
the lawless one will be revealed whom
the lord will consume with the breath of
his mouth destroy with the brightness of
his coming
the coming of the lawless one is
according to the working of satan with
power signs and lying wonders what's
that power signs lying wonder it's
spiritualism
and with the unrighteous deception among
those who perish why did they perish
they did
not receive the love of the truth that
they might be saved for this reason god
will send them a strong delusion that
they should believe a lie
that they all may be condemned who did
not believe the truth but add pleasure
and unrighteousness
how can we keep from being deceived in
the last days
by loving the truth
by loving god's word
and by loving the author of truth jesus
said i am the way
the truth
and the life
as i love jesus
i love his word
as i love jesus i love his teachings
as i love jesus i love his truth
to love jesus is to love the things that
jesus taught and want to live in harmony
with them
the devil
will deceive multitudes in the last days
but you and i need not be deceived
because we have the sure word of truth
that shines like a light in the darkness
of this word
embrace it
follow it
live in harmony with it
and by the grace and power of the holy
spirit
jesus will take you by the hand and lead
you to eternity let's pray
father in heaven how thankful we are for
the word of god that protects us in the
last days of earth's history from the
wiles of satan and spiritualism keep us
faithful to you
keep us trusting you
help our eyes be fixed upon you
and may the words of christ i am the way
the truth and the life be burned into
our hearts help us to know
that
to the law and to the testimony if they
keep if they live not according to his
word there is no light in them help us
to follow
your principles of your law
with christ enshrined in our hearts and
the holy spirit strengthening us we pray
in jesus name amen we love it when you
send in questions we'd love to answer
your bible questions
and when you are
watching our programs and god touches
your heart you make a decision for
christ and you send that into us we
really appreciate that if you have any
questions we'd love to answer them at
info
at
hope
lives365.com that's info at hope
lives365.com look forward to your
questions